hello and welcome to this video first
even the session and you get you get the
yard bird what is my score minus 80 k I
mean I won 22 games but how Hans the
lost 30 game so we should be for Queens
gambit it is and it's not not among the
most threatening lines so hmm yeah in
fact this is not good for a while at all
but we'll see what happens Queen a5 is a
move now check yep 92 was running into a
pretty awkward pin so he had to do this
okay how to place pieces now I think I
won't be five yeah this is this is
actually threatening to sacrifice on age
77 I have to take that into account okay
96 is now possible a team hmm yeah
should be seven is not exactly a spot i
imagined for my bishop but maybe i have
to or queen bee six maybe queen bee six
queen on a5 is pretty dumb anyway now it
was ok only five to provoke them the
whole king move that that thing but
otherwise it doesn't make some more
sense so I think 97 should be right
getting rid of that centralized piece
and now go from here what to do now we
should be six maybe
yeah I guess that's okay yeah i was
thinking f5 oh no f5 is good locking
things yeah here i would love to play a
4 but that gives him the check
unfortunately still I don't see a big
problem here them in my position I've
got three against two and the best that
you can do is play a foreign block the
hole centres entirely so I can never be
worse in this position only question is
how much better am I not see javi goes
g6 I play age six and vice versa so now
fvf form might be on in some cases so
not sure maybe has to play it himself he
allows me to check here that's weird but
I don't have and cringing to Quincy
three days now it's no easy way of
getting there I'm trying to say is it's
just a check I don't really have much
more I can give a couple of checks and
take g5 actually so maybe I should do
that thank you check it's no reason not
to take that so now I guess f4 is right
or not I mean he might invade them with
the Queen but
it's not threatening much yeah I could
counter attack the you three Pawn maybe
just here so that Queenie 7 will attack
the pawn okay let's go back and now w on
the on the pond I was threatening F form
if I go g5 now and I think I can might
be able to threaten that and now I'm
doubling on the EVO yeah yeah ok this is
really matter I could have thought about
it but it's not important
threatening III sc3 now
I only have to be alert to tricks some
kind of trickery based on the h6 pawn
that there is made on just happened with
the queen or something like that so um
yeah i think i can get will see three
there's nothing really wrong with that
so g5 not yet but I can threaten that g5
and then f form
what about the time a little bit behind
but it's not not awfully little one time
a g5 is a pretty substantial threat
500 f 1 and then III and D Fogle will
crumble and I don't see a way for him to
enter my position with him it was Queen
c7 he also has to reckon with
discoveries of the Bishop Bishop a 4
immediately is displayable even yeah we
should pay for or F form yeah I see no
reason to avoid F form he cannot take or
move the e porn so I will take that next
i have opened up as bishop though the
sea to bishop some and something to take
into account i think taking with the
pawn and then g4 stampin up the position
as much as possible
it takes on d5 I can't eat like this
it's pretty much over yeah that didn't
go too well for him right out of the
opening let's go all the way back yeah
that line with nine bd7 is fairly solid
I don't think Roxy oneness is dangerous
at all the reason is that after c5 now
white well why doesn't really have some
decent alternative to the captcha on d5
okay you can play some slow move but in
many cases we will get something that is
kind of okay for black especially
considering that I could maybe give him
an isolated pawn so let's just say it
would move the bishop for argument's
sake and something like that it's nice
because the bishop now has moved two
times I will get a temple on it and the
further 95 would even gained another
tempo on the bishop on a forum in
general the bishop is not very well
placed on f4 in and I QP position so the
capture is pretty much what they all
play and here the issue is that any
check like here are sometimes with the
bishop is quite annoying as he doesn't
have any night to interpose anymore on
c3 in the Queen check even would pick up
the porn so it's something very very
young yeah important to take into
account yeah I could play that already
however it is not entirely clear if I
can take the pawn I probably can do that
but why does of course very well
developed so I preferred that went back
out of the check yeah now why does to
either move the king or move the night
and if you move the night this is not a
very convenient situation yeah I mean
the engine suggests this kind of thing
yeah but I can also go b5 for example ok
the king move that's a very risky
decision I think
okay but it is an interesting player
this is what it always is after I think
that failed okay oh the engine does not
like my at all it wants to go Quincy to
now with a big advantage this idea now I
cannot move my knight that's a very true
now the engine wants to play this move
wow that doesn't look good it was a big
chance that he had here but he played
this quite quickly and now i'm probably
all right after the nitrate at least i
should be okay g5 yeah the engine
already gives me a pretty clear
advantage yeah I was thinking the same
because I'm having those three pawns
against tomb so those pawns will be
dangerous they can easily form a passer
quite quickly while the eeprom is pretty
useless oh I can never go here as it
opens up his King position and this is
not threatening much the pawns as I can
always play the other porn so on g6 I go
and yeah on h6 they go g6 and if he goes
g6 like oh age 60 i can always close
that position like here and here why
doesn't have any plane yeah this was
funny he just gave me that the pawn shop
return check yeah just gave me that pawn
okay put pressure on the e porn and i
think i did an okay job maybe something
quicker was possible but it wasn't
wasn't bad i know it approaches minus 3
minus 4 territory c3 here
sticks rookie a rookie one and now a
Quincy six is a strong the bishop is not
having many squares this is a big issue
something like this is don't write lost
hmm so okay i just went back I don't
think it's a mistake no that's also like
minus side or something okay I could
have taken tea for you but that that
wins a line that I had seen was this no
Bishop g4 maybe that's not the quickest
win but it wins this was a large check
check and I should meet him I didn't
calculate till the end but I saw that it
should be made somewhere so after that
he resigned yeah interesting game he had
a big chance there with Quincy to at one
point but after that I was serve in very
okay shape okay well thanks for watching